Deutschland in der Energiekrise ein Land
steht am Abgrund das Gas ist knapp doch
Gott sei Dank am Horizont erscheint ein
Licht der Hoffnung die Höhe Esperanza
Deutschlands erstes schwimmendes
flüssiggasterminal und genau dieses
Terminal werden wir gemeinsam mit
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz eröffnen
moin schön hier im Norden doch eins nach
dem anderen der Abend zuvor
Behaglichkeit im Scheine wohlverteilter
Lampen und dazu ein wohltuender Tee die
Energieversorgung ist endgültig
gesichert selbst die Wissenschaft vor
Ort ist begeistert Frau Dr Kämpfer hat
endlich haben wir in Wilhelmshaven das
erste LMG Terminal endlich sind alle
Probleme gelöst sind sie auch so happy
wie der Bundeskanzler nein ich bin
überhaupt nicht happy das ist
tatsächlich so dass hier jetzt das
dreckigste Flüssigkeit Schiff an landet
welches man weltweit
aktiv den wir da Deutschland
unterwegs ist was keiner haben will weil
das so umweltschädlich ist und das kommt
jetzt hier an ist tatsächlich hoch
problematisch weil der Biozide und Chlor
ins Wasser eingeschlossen werden
das ist ein hochproblematischer Stoff
weil gerade für das Wattenmeer hier wir
befinden uns hier im Naturerbe
Wattenmeer und deswegen ist das
problematisch ja gut Weltkulturerbe
Warten mehr brauchen wir das denn
wirklich also wir brauchen das Welt er
natürlich was mir das ist ja total
wichtig dass wir Naturschutz haben
letztendlich ist Ansichtssache Match und
ein bisschen jetzt mit Chlor ja also
genau
das ist schon schön also das sollten wir
auch erhalten kennen sie das sie sitzen
frieren und energiesparend auf der Couch
und plötzlich schießt ihn aus heiterem
Himmel eine Frage durch den Kopf wie
könnte das eigentlich passieren dass
unser Gast vor dem Ukraine kriegt so 55%
aus Russland kam wie jede schlechte
Kriminalgeschichte beginnt auch diese
mit einem schwierigen Geschäftsmann aus
Hannover
Schröders Regierung setzte 2002 die
Fusion von E.ON und Ruhrgas durch obwohl
das bundeskartell am damals vor einer zu
großen Abhängigkeit von zum gaswand ich
erlaube mir an dieser Stelle ein kleines
lol denn die Spätfolge dieser
mega-fusion von damals ist
uneper Deutschlands größter und
wichtigster gasvorsorger Juniper kennen
Sie daher weil sie die gerade mit
schätzungsweise über 30 Milliarden
Steuergeld retten nee ich habe es mir
anders überlegt ich will die Geschichte
doch nicht mehr hören dann zeige ich
euch stattdessen wie Putin mit
Champagner anstößt aber warum stößt er
an weil es schon 2006 Gaslieferungen als
Druckmittel gegen andere Länder benutzt
hat und es uns egal war oder weil er
2014 die kriminiert hat und wir kurz
danach losstream 2 beschließen oder
wollen wir 2015 den größten deutschen
verkauft haben
hatten wir denn allen Vogel
der mehrere es ist soweit das Terminal
wird eröffnet über 10.000 Journalisten
haben sich angekündigt deshalb kann
leider nur einer von uns mit an Bord der
andere von uns muss hin schwimmen
da gehe ich nicht rein ich gehe auf
Schiff aber es kann nur einer von uns
Ausschüssen
Urlaub geschickt du hast keine duale
Energie
ich ja die hat sich dann nach entwickelt
ich habe eine Chlorallergie ich muss
aufs Schiffen du kannst hin schwimmen
schnick schnack schnuck ja habe ich
gewonnen naja wie du eine Runde das
fühlt man noch drei Runden
7 Uhr 17 - 4 Grad ich werde das
Abenteuer wagen auch einige Anwohner
sind gekommen sie wollen noch ein
letztes Mal in ihrer Nordsee schwimmen
bevor sie mit Chlor vollgepumpt wird ich
bin Einwohner von Hooks betroffen durch
den Einsatz dieses Schiffes Esperanza
und wir sind überhaupt nicht damit
einverstanden dass man jedes Jahr jetzt
180 Milliarden Liter mit hypothurid und
homophoben verseuchten Wasser wieder in
Jade lässt klar wenn wir jetzt einen
grünen Wirtschaftsminister hätten ne
dann wäre es verhindert worden aber so
kann man nichts machen ne wir hatten ja
grüne Umweltminister der das alles
angeschoben hat der war ja noch
umweltmeister und der neue ist ja im Tal
der Ahnungslosen also wir sehen uns dann
auf dem Schiff ne ich muss dann jetzt
auch los weil da gibt es auch
Schnittchen und toi toi toi
nein
ich
nicht starten nein
[Musik]
schon angenehm jetzt hier in diesem
warmen Bus zu sein und mit den Gedanken
bin ich natürlich bei meinem guten
Freund Lutz der gerade mit den Wellen
kämpft
Leute
und jetzt liebe Zuschauer zu Hause
können Sie einfach mal selber raten was
meinen Sie was ist schwerer so ein
riesiges Terminal in einem halben Jahr
in den Meeresboden zu stampfen oder ein
Windrad zu bauen für das wir aktuell 6
Jahre brauchen
schwierig
[Musik]
einmal an Bord wollte man mich partout
nicht mit den großen politischen
Entscheidern ins Gespräch bringen weil
sie zu Recht befürchteten dass ich
meinen Senf dazu gebe doch ich habe da
so Techniken entwickelt zum Beispiel
uninteressiert gucken und dann
blitzschnell zu schlagen das Habeck und
Scholz hier sind verstehe ich ja was ist
mit ihnen haben sich auf dem Weg nach
Sylt Verfahren
sie müssen noch nachlegen noch mehr
nachlegen
gut lege ich halt noch einen nach aber
dann wenigstens bei jemand wichtigem
herr Scholz schön sie zu sehen
herzlichen Glückwunsch erstmal dass das
so schnell ging moin schön hier im
Norden es ist ja schon absurd dass das
jetzt hier in einem halben Jahr alles
geklappt hat und es dauert bei
Windrädern 6 Jahre um als aufzustellen
ich meine das ist zwei Jahre länger als
ihre gesamte Kanzlerschaft ich glaube da
sind was die Länge der Kanzlerschaft
betrifft und auch was die Dauer der
genehmigungsform Verfahren für
Windkraftanlagen bitte für die Zukunft
auch denn wir haben uns das ja hier zum
Vorbild genommen mit Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit die Dinge voranzubringen
und haben schon jetzt viele Gesetze
gemacht damit es bei den
Windkraftanlagen besser geht und haben
noch ziemlich viele weitere in der
Pipeline ja brauchen wir denn um die
Energiewende jetzt doch noch schnell
voranzubringen einen energischen
charismatischen Macher
ich finde wir haben einen energischen
mache
Charisma und das läuft hier ganz gut
unter der von mir geführten Regierung wo
ist denn Robert Habeck der ist hier
sehr gut bitte sagen sie mussten sich ja
vor dem Emir verbeugen Kohlekraftwerke
weiterlaufen lassen Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen lassen und jetzt werden
hier für ein Gast Terminal Millionen
Liter an Chlor ins Meer geleitet ich
meine Frage ist einfach nur wollen sie
einen Taschentuch haben sie werden es
noch brauchen oder
haben sie die Alternative überlegt man
hätte das Schiff doch auch umrüsten
können
zu was es gibt auch mechanische
Verfahren um dieses Gas umzuwandeln wir
mussten ja im Winter jetzt ernsthaft ich
weiß wir kommen die schon aber es ist
gar nicht lustig wir müssen im Winter
die Versorgungssicherheit hinbekommen
werden wir es denn auch irgendwann mal
schaffen dass auch Windräder so schnell
gebaut werden können das wäre das
Projekt ja ganz toll toll ist es denn
überhaupt ein richtiger Eröffnung eines
Gas Terminals wenn Gerd Schröder nicht
dabei ist
das finde ich lustige Frage aber der hat
sich ja mehr Pipeline gekümmert und
nicht um Termin für Flüssigkeit
[Musik]
herzlich gefunden Leute ich habe mich
ich habe alles gegeben das Scheiße
gefunden
für meinen Körper nicht mehr
fortsetzung folgt
Fabian Lutz ich bin hier hier folgt
meiner Stimme ah ich habe dich jetzt
übertreiben die das aber mit dem
Energiesparen oder sogar in der endcard
klickt HIER wenn ihr abonnieren wollt
oder hier für weitere Videos
wo geht's denn jetzt hier raus ich
glaube da lang ja mein Fuß